he's my second favorite bar after open
bill barr is out with a brand new book
one damn thing after another memoirs of
an attorney general so let's ask him
about it okay first of all a lot of
people don't know this okay you were
attorney general twice uh jor under
george h.w bush
and donald trump and obviously one was
very loud obnoxious and crass and the
other you know was donald trump
what was it what was the how was how
would you compare the working for both
of them
[Laughter]
they were both very different kinds of
people yes um and uh
trump was very interesting and a bit
more of a challenge right yes
did i put you on the spot
no i think it's i think uh you know i
think people just he he's such
an outsized character
and you have to like in a way you have
to manage it's a case of where you have
to manage your boss at least that's how
i look at myself
cat and i look at it the same way yes
yes
tell me the story uh about the fight and
it was a story that you told donald
trump as a kind of a piece of advice
right so he had already offered me the
job one day and then a few days later he
asked me to stop by again to visit him
and i realized this was
reopening of the thing which was fine
with me and i said to him uh
at the toward the end i said you know mr
president you and i are going to have a
problem we're going to be disagreeing uh
and he said oh really on what and i said
because you believe in po he kept on
telling the importance of punching back
i said you punch back right away
which me lets the other guy pick the
time in place of the fight right so let
me tell you this story i said i was
playing football at columbia you know
with my fraternity against another
fraternity this guy threw sand in my
eyes and i acted like no big deal and
the game went on for two two hours
and afterward as we were walking back up
to the campus
i meted out justice i decked the guy and
he
and the president was happy that the
story had a happy ending
but he said but he didn't get the point
and i said you see your way mr president
you would have fought right away you
would have attacked them everyone would
have held you back
the game would have never been played
and you never would have gotten justice
at the end
did he appreciate the the the moral to
that story
obviously not
he's gonna punch
did your team cover the spread more
i don't really care about the fight i
mean look at the outfit i'm trying to
make some money here
um could i add one thing to that because
you talked about the clash in styles how
many days into the job before you asked
yourself why the hell you took the job
uh zero really i said it before
[Laughter]
you were close to retiring i was i was
essentially quasi retired i was on
boards and doing things like that and i
didn't want to go back in but i i did
eventually well i think you i i think
you're presented with that conflict of
words versus deeds which is that you
might not like trump's personality but
you really liked his policies and and
it is like you know i hate his tweets
but now you don't have his tweets
anymore but now you've got inflation
right you know you have and you have
crime and it's like i'll take i'll take
his i'll take his kind of uh combative
combative behavior i was happy with his
administration up until the point of the
election it took some wrestling to
sometimes keep him on track but what
people think of as obnoxious traits
sometimes had a good side to him right
his impulsiveness yes right it could get
you in trouble you had to sometimes
fight him to keep things on track but on
the other hand
it lent dynamism to the administration
he could roll over the bureaucratic
inertia this is what's so important i
thought right and we i mean and we have
the opposite now
like we have we have actual kind of like
helpless inertia yeah they don't make
decisions yeah they don't make decisions
and and you kind of wish they wouldn't
make any because they make wrong ones if
true if um trump decides to run into
well first do you think he's gonna run
in 2024 i think he right now thinks he's
gonna run yeah yeah and uh would you
support him if he became the nominee
well if he became the nominee uh i would
support the republican candidate because
i think the greatest threat to the
country is the progressive agenda and
i'm not going to vote for the democrats
yeah so i would support them but
i i think that would be a mistake for
the republican party you know oh who do
you like clearly kanye listen
[Laughter]
so
bright this is your first book that you
wrote yes what was the most difficult
part when you're writing your life story
what was the toughest part when you put
it on paper did was there anything any
anything in particular the fun part was
the early years and the bush years uh
the hard part was the trump years and it
was hard because it's hard to catch
nuance in today's age yeah everyone is
going to want to pigeonhole what you say
and take this sentence out of context
and this
and i tried to be fair fair and balanced
with trump yeah and i you know i think
trump deserves a lot of credit for
coming at a time where the country i
thought was being pushed over the abyss
by
the progressive agenda and he put a stop
to it it has to be all
or nothing the greatest president that
ever was or the devil and you can't and
you can't be anywhere in the middle but
the words versus deeds philosophy always
addresses that that if you just look at
the deeds that what he do what he's done
it's important
and then you can look at the words and
go okay you know amazing listen nobody
overdosed on fentanyl because trump
called rosie o'donnell a hog yeah i mean
[Laughter]
the book is called one damn thing after
another buy it
or i'll never talk to you again
up next can bass pass math class hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else